just when you thought it couldn't get
any cuter than this moment with Kate
Middleton and her four-year-old daughter
Princess Charlotte at last week's King's
Cup Regatta think again Hughley surfaced
photos from the charity event held at
the isle of wight in england show an
adorable exchange between the duchess
and a young fan in the pics the little
girl who looks to be around Charlotte's
age Kim's a mighty bow after presenting
Kate with a small bouquet of roses
what's even better is the little tots
colourful ice cream dress unicorn face
paint and tiny horn the mom of three
seemed tickled by the girls sweet
gesture
kate is you know she's very broody just
as she did her own daughter's hilarious
toddler moment a move reminiscent of her
Uncle Harry when he was around the same
age we want to get a special prize for
the teams that came in last place
Kate ultimately lost the charity Cup
after her boat was disqualified in the
second race but she didn't go home
empty-handed please welcome to the stage
or say hello to on the stage the Duchess
of Cambridge to collect this spoon this
is the first time the Duchess has ever
finished last in anything I could
guarantee so you better enjoy
congratulations well done well done
indeed between the adorable photos of
Prince William teasing Kate Middleton
about the large prize her sweet moments
with little girls and six year old
Prince George stealing our hearts with
his toothless grin we'd say the day was
overall a huge success
you